-It is time for "Tonight Show
Hashtags," everybody.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Hashtags ♪
♪♪
-We do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to respond
to that topic.
So, since it's the start
of summer blockbuster season,
I sent out the hashtag...
...where I asked you guys
to take a movie title
and add one word
to change the meaning.
Within minutes
of sending it out,
it was the number 1
trending topic in the U.S.,
[ Cheering and applause ]
so, thank you for playing along.
And now,
I thought I'd share some
of my favorite...
...tweets from you guys.
This first one is
from @Dua-zahra313.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, interesting.
I'd watch that.
This next one's
from @AlohaDelilah75.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh.
He actually works behind the
register in this one, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Next one is from @hoho4.
It says...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
This next one is
from @SpennyHiggs.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one is from @FeldFam.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one is
from @Ricketylicks.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, interesting.
-Oh.
-Classic.
This next one is
from @TheoPlaya2.
-TheoPlaya2?
-TheoPlaya2, yep.
He says --
-Not 1?
-No, this is 2.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
There you go.
[ Laughter and applause ]
This next one's
from @elizabethk1985.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ooh.
♪♪
[ Baritone ]
Oh, yeah.
-♪ Ooh! ♪
-[ Baritone ]
Hershey's.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This next one is
from @KyleShamorian.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Okay, yeah, just click Accept.
And this last one is
from @MyTweetStink.
They say...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites, go to...